du pain du pain et encore du pain dans
ses locaux de Houilles une douzaine de
bénévoles à faire ils font partie de
l'antenne de l'association Saint-Vincent
de Paul qui lutte contre la solitude des
personnes handicapées malades ou encore
âgées de matinée par semaine c'est
bénévoles vont faire le tour des
commerces pour collecter le pain invendu
nous allons avoir
les trois lieux de collecte qu'on
retrouve un peu sur l'ensemble de ces
deux villes où et carrières c'est-à-dire
un supermarché une boulangerie et puis
donc
l'église de Notre-Dame du réveil matin
on a commencé par une boulangerie puis
deux un supermarché et que
progressivement l'activité s'est étendue
aujourd'hui à tous les producteurs de
pain pratiquement de la ville de
Houilles et des villes de Houilles et de
carrière donc là on arrive à la panière
pour les particuliers qui viennent ici
dans cette église de réveil matin ou
effectivement nous allons pouvoir
récupérer
des baguettes et on s'est aperçu qu'en
fait
c'est très compliqué il faut reconnaître
aussi bien pour les boulangers que pour
les supermarchés de savoir exactement
les quantités qu'ils vont vendre c'est
ce qui explique que finalement il y a
tant de pain qui donc
ne soit pas vendu et du coup ils étaient
heureux de savoir qu'il y a un débouché
qui leur permet d'éviter que ce pain
aille à la poubelle ici plus de 10
tonnes de pain transit par an parfois
les dents récollectés sont encore
consommables non c'est pour l'épicerie
donc de côté on mettra dans la salle
nous récoltons le pain mais il peut y
avoir aussi des viennoiseries des
brioches et donc qui vont être
redistribués donc au Secours populaire
d'une part il y a l'épice sociale la
plupart du temps le pain collecté est
séché puis broyé à l'aide de deux
machines l'objectif est d'en faire de la
chapelure qui sera redist évolué à
l'association pain contre la faim la
chapelure rentre dans la composition
d'APA pour la pêche et permet de
réinsérer 20 à 30 personnes chômeurs de
longue durée par an cette activité de
réinsertion et réaliser par notre
partenaire pain contre la faim qui est à
charte et qui vient donc chercher cette
chapelure ah oui régulièrement depuis
les nouvelles contraintes de réduction
d'énergie l'association ne peut plus
faire chauffer ses locaux pour faire
sécher le pain en hiver le pain collecté
sera directement distribué une fois par
semaine à pain contrôle afin